et nous poursuivons
nos travaux de ce jour par une audition
commune
[Musique]
sur les enjeux juridiques nationaux et
internationaux du débat sur la fin de
vie après avoir entendu les
philosophes la semaine passée après un
déplacement en Belgique
et bientôt en Suisse et après les
les propos du président de la République
lundi faisant ensuite à la Convention
citoyenne nous poursuivons ce travail
j'indique que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat qui sera ensuite disponible en
vidéo à la demande
donc cette mission je l'ai déjà dit
s'inscrit dans le cadre des travaux que
nous menons sur la question de la fin de
vie menée par nos rapporteurs Christine
Bonfanti Dossa que ce prix d'excuser
mais elle avait un problème de train et
donc elle a dû partir plus tôt beaucoup
de travail aurait annulés Corinne Imbert
et Michel meunier ou en plénière comme
ce fut le cas la semaine passée nous
avons donc le plaisir d'accueillir
madame Bénédicte Boyer
maître de conférence en droit privé à
l'Université Paris 8 Vincennes
Saint-Denis Madame Valérie de Pape de
comment on dit de pas de pain mettre de
conférences endroit privé à l'Université
Paris 13 Sorbonne Parinor et Monsieur
Julien Jeannet professeur de droit
public à l'Université de Strasbourg je
vous propose donc de commencer par un
propos liminaire relativement bref
afin de laisser toute leur place aux
échanges qui suivront
vous voyez bien vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs donc en fait toute la
question est de savoir si aujourd'hui la
fin de vie est dans une situation
satisfaisante notamment du point de vue
législatif alors tout d'abord je crois
que c'est très très important de dire
que la fin de vie à l'hôpital ou encore
à domicile et un suffisante donc au
niveau matériel au niveau humain et
au niveau de l'organisation des hôpitaux
alors pour vous faire une idée en 2019
26 départements ne disposaient pas
d'unités de soins palliatifs et d'au
moins un lit pour 100000 habitants donc
il convient avant tout de prendre en
considération cette situation puisque à
quoi bon faire de multiples lois
successives
si initialement dans la pratique
l'hôpital
la santé de fin de vie les soins
palliatifs
ne marchent pas et ne mettent pas en
application la loi déjà existante
convient-il de changer la loi c'est une
question
alors je dirais que personnellement je
n'ai pas à prendre par une telle
question mais par contre au regard du
droit et au regard de l'éthique c'est
une question qui est vraiment
fondamentale
nous avons l'article L
1110-5 du Code de Santé publique qui dit
que toute personne a le droit d'avoir
une fin digne
accompagnée du meilleur apaisement
apaisement possible de la souffrance
donc vous êtes d'accord on ne peut pas
laisser les personnes souffrir tandis
conditions abominables lorsqu'elles sont
en fin de vie alors si on les Juifs
pourquoi et bien parce qu'il y a des
limites dans la loi
donc jusqu'à présent on a prévu la
sédation profonde et continue pour les
personnes qui étaient en soins
palliatifs et dont la vie est abrégé à
court terme donc vous voyez on a choisi
le législateur à choisir le court terme
or le Comité consultatif national
d'éthique dans son avis 139 montre du
doigt le fait que vous avez des
personnes qui sont en soins palliatifs
qui sont à moyen terme ou à long terme
dans une situation extrêmement difficile
à des situations de gros souffrances
donc on ne peut pas les laisser dans de
telles situations
première question fondamentale est-ce
qu'il conviendra
d'envisager la sédation profonde on en
parle pas beaucoup de cette sédation
profonde vous voyez on parle beaucoup de
l'euthanasie du succès d'assister et
aujourd'hui la loi prévoit la sédation
profonde mais à court terme donc la
sédation à moyen terme pourquoi pas être
une situation intermédiaire donc on
pourrait reprendre des situations enfin
les mêmes enfin des règles analogues
mais le problème le problème dans une
telle hypothèse c'est qu'on n'a pas
assez de recherches sur la souffrance
la souffrance que peuvent ressentir les
personnes lorsqu'elles sont endormis
donc c'est une question difficile mais
je pense qu'il est important quand même
de l'évoquer
autre question
qu'on vient-il d'envisager le suicide
assisté c'est-à-dire l'aide à mourir par
une prescription médicale de produits
létal ou encore l'euthanasie donc là
c'est le médecin qui va aussi prescrire
le produit létal et qui va réaliser
l'acte situation extrêmement complexe
qui reste vraiment difficile à réfléchir
et vous parlementaire vous avez un rôle
très très important à lire pour bien
voir un petit peu cette balance entre
les éléments positifs et les éléments
négatifs alors déjà le l'euthanasie ou
le système et bien il ne faut à mon sens
limité dans la loi dans la suite de la
dans la succession des lois qu'on a eu
jusqu'à là uniquement dans des cas très
très très exceptionnel
notamment comme je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure lorsque la loi ne peut pas
prendre en considération le moyen terme
ou la le terme dans la souffrance
réfractaire il faut limiter ça aussi aux
soins palliatifs
la question aussi qui viendra se greffer
là-dessus ce sont les risques si on fait
de l'euthanasie si on autorise
l'euthanasie ou encore si on autorise le
suicide assisté
comment va-t-on pouvoir
évaluer
l'autonomie de la volonté c'est très
très important de bien prendre des
mesures dans ce sens il ne faut pas
faire n'importe quoi donc ce sera
d'autant plus important que les
personnes sont atteintes de grandes
fragilité de grandes souffrances donc
l'autonomie de la volonté va peser des
difficultés pour les apprécier nous
avons aussi les risques de
stigmatisation sociale les risques de
stigmatisation professionnelle
et même les risques
d'autostigmatisation c'est à dire que la
personne va se dire je suis en fin de
vie je suis un fardeau je suis un
fardeau pour ma famille et peut-être
même que un jour l'hôpital surtout qu'il
y a pas beaucoup de lit va se dire on
n'a pas de place on a peu de on n'a pas
de place on a peu de de lire en soi
palliatifs c'est ce qui existe déjà dans
la réalité
bon peut-être qu'on va plus aller dans
le soin dans le dans l'euthanasie
la question qui se pose c'est la
proportionnalité la proportionnalité
c'est à dire entre l'apaisement qu'on
peut apporter aux personnes
et entre les risques qui peuvent exister
pour protéger la personne à chaque fois
vous voyez la finalité c'est la
protection des individus dans une très
grande vulnérabilité
alors bien sûr on a pour pouvoir évaluer
cette proportionnalité mes collègues
vont pouvoir développer davantage après
tous les grands principes principes de
dignité principe de liberté principe
d'égalité principe de solidarité
l'importe aussi de réfléchir c'est la
situation des professionnels de santé
professionnelle de santé qui ont été
largement éprouvés déjà par rapport à la
situation de l'hôpital mais aussi par
rapport au sermon d'Hippocrate ils ont
toujours été habitués à soigner la
personne donc pour eux c'est difficile
de pouvoir donner la mort par rapport à
l'euthanasie ou encore par rapport
au suicide assisté donc je crois qu'il
faut aller dans le sens de la clause de
conscience qui est aussi un moyen de
leur laisser la liberté de choisir ou
pas alors après il y a une garantie
c'est que s'il y a une clause de
conscience c'est de renvoyer la personne
vers une autre un autre professionnel de
santé donc il y a cette possibilité là
mais on pourrait aussi prévoir une autre
possibilité créer 5 ou 6 unités dans
toute la France qui en charge les
personnes atteintes de sédation profonde
et enfin oui atteint de pardon qui
souhaiterait faire de l'euthanasie et en
fait ça serait des services complètement
dédiés et ça serait un déchargera le
poids des professionnels de santé donc
rapidement il convient aussi de prévoir
des services très très spécifiques pour
la prise en charge des personnes il
convient aussi de prévoir des
financements dédiés aussi bien dans les
établissements que par rapport à la
tarification adaptée
concernant les 10 actes
et pour terminer
je vais insister sur ce point on en
parle pas du tout c'est l'accessibilité
du droit
aujourd'hui vous avez une partie et des
dispositions légales qui sont
concentrées dans la partie législative
du code de la santé publique et vous
avez beaucoup beaucoup de dispositions
qui sont dans le dans le code enfin
toujours dans le code de la santé
publique mais dans le code de
déontologie médicale le code de
déontologie médiale de déontologie
médicale c'est un outil pour les
médecins
mais
les personnes de la société ne vont pas
forcément lire le code de déontologie
médicale alors que toutes il y a
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
dispositions qui sont dans ce code de
déontologie médicale et qu'on ne
retrouve pas dans la partie
réglementaire donc je crois qu'il sera
important à la fois de restructurer
le droit de la fin de vie c'est à dire
mettre tout en dans une partie
spécifique du code de la santé publique
pour que les gens puissent ouvrir le
code et voir tout ce qui existe et
rapatrier certaines dispositions qui
sont dans le cas de déontologie médicale
dans la partie réglementaire pour que ça
soit accessible à tous et bien sûr dans
le code de déontologie médicale les
médecins prévoient toujours leur propre
disposition pour prendre en charge la
fin de vie voilà je vous remercie merci
Madame à vous de
ne pas merci madame la Présidente
mesdames les sénatrices monsieur les
sénateurs je voudrais liminairement vous
dire que je vais me permettre de parler
du ressenti des médecins parce que je
travaille de façon assez étroite avec
eux voilà je pense qu'un juriste seul
dans ces questions est impuissant qu'il
faut de l'humidité quand on fait du
droit face aux professionnels donc c'est
pour ça que je me permettrai de parler
de leur ressenti alors parmi les
questions qui se posent pour entrer dans
le vif du sujet bien il faut distinguer
la situation de la personne dont le
pronostic vital est engagé à court terme
très court terme et celle dont le
pronostic vital est engagé par la
maladie mais à plus long terme
le droit actuel répond aux situations
d'extrême fan de vie on autorisant la
sédation profonde et continue ce type de
sédation qui est à des apports majeurs
de la loi de 2016 dans la loi de 2016 ce
type de sédation a été conçu je crois
qu'il faut bien l'avoir en tête comme
une mesure de soulagement de lutte
contre la souffrance pas un moyen de
mettre fin à la vie et en ce sens cette
sédation ne contrevient pas au sermant
Hippocrate ce qui l'a rendu beaucoup
plus facile enfin oui plus aisé
accepter pour les médecins
et pourtant les médecins apparaissent
réticents certains médecins dans
certains cas mais assez fréquents
apparaissent réticents face à ce qui
s'interroge il s'interroge à plusieurs
titres que vit et prouve le patient
certes il est endormi mais que vit qui
éprouvent-ils
à quel niveau ta conscience est-il rendu
et aussi et surtout parce que c'est le
médecin se préoccupent des tiques quel
sens donner à ce temps à ce temps de
sommeil de sommeil artificiel du point
de vue du patient et aussi parce que la
question
est à mon avis secondaire mais
importante que vit la famille qui
parfois voit le corps donner des marques
de souffrance
or ce temps est très variable lorsque ce
type de sédation est appliqué à un
patient pour lequel un prélèvement
d'organes de type masse riche 3
c'est-à-dire sur coeur arrêté est
envisagé et bien les médecins arrête le
respirateur et le délai le délai qui
sépare l'arrêt des suppléances vitales
du constat de décès par arrêt cardiaque
et d'environ 15 minutes
Vincent Lambert monsieur Vincent Lambert
patient neurocéral est resté c'est daté
neuf jours avant de décéder 9 jours qui
ont été puisque l'affaire a été
malheureusement médiatisée on sait que
ces journées ont été très difficiles à
vivre pour les proches alors on voit ici
à quel temps le point de la sédation
peut varier or raccourcir le temps de la
sédation lorsqu'elle se prolonge
implique évidemment d'injecter au
patients des doses létales ce que ça
fait les médecins mais alors il ne
s'agit plus d'une sédation comme elle
est entendue par la loi puisque le
dosage aura pour but d'abréger la vie
alors je suis bien consciente de poser
le problème sans y apporter de solution
mais bon nous comptons
au-delà de ces questions la sédation
profonde et continue ne peut répondre
aux situations dans lesquelles le
pronostic vital n'est pas engagé à court
terme parce qu'alors d'abord elle serait
longue et signe de souffrance seraient
apparent le temps de l'inconnu
s'éterniserait et la personne ne
décéderait pas des causes de sa maladie
elle décéderait d'infections multiples
aussi faut-il vous faut-il aborder la
question aussi difficile soit elle d'une
assistance au suicide voire d'une
euthanasie notre président très
récemment a fait savoir souhaiter
l'élaboration d'un modèle français de
fin de vie
il me semble que cette expression
souligne toute la difficulté de la
transcription juridique d'un droit à
l'aide d'active à mourir il va falloir
le transcrire mais ce sera une tâche
particulièrement difficile cette
expression à mon sens signifie que la
loi ne peut simplement acter la volonté
des Français quant à l'ouverture d'un
droit à une adaptique à une adaptative à
mourir
elle doit lactée dans le respect des
valeurs essentielles d'humanité de
solidarité d'accompagnement des plus
vulnérables qui sont les nôtres
et en ce sens la loi sur la fin de vie
doit d'abord apporter des propositions
de vie en réponse au crainte que les
Français expriment d'être abandonnés en
situation de souffrance
alors de ce point de vue les deux
questions évidemment de l'offre de soins
palliatifs et d'un droit à choisir le
moment de son décès sont liés elles sont
différentes mais elles sont liées dans
le temps l'insuffisance des soins
palliatifs fausse le débat parce que
dans le paysage désolé désolant des
soins de vie l'aide à mourir ne devra
jamais devenir un moyen d'éviter
l'agonie
si une procédure d'assistance à une mort
anticipée quelle qu'en soit
l'appellation devait être légalement
institué elle ne devrait pouvoir être
mise en application sans que l'ensemble
des soins médicaux possibles
techniquement possible envisageable en
état des possibilités scientifiques
aient été préalablement proposé au
patients des soins de qualité et des
quand je dis de qualité
une qualité de temporelle c'est-à-dire
des soins qui puissent être dispensés le
temps nécessaire parce que s'il en est
autrement l'Adaptive à mourir
représentera une alternative par défaut
à des soins de vie de fin de vie de
qualité
alors la question de l'aide active ne
peut se poser qu'en cas d'impuissance de
la médecine à calmer la souffrance
les médecins expliquent qu'une fois la
douleur y compris psychique apaisé la
demande de mort devient exceptionnelle
elle existe mais elle devient
exceptionnelle
dès lors que le maintien de cette
demande apparaît en pratique
exceptionnelle
dès lors que des soins palliatifs sont
dispensés n'est-ce pas uniquement ces
cas exceptionnels que doit relayer la
loi pardon en permettant les dossiers
n'ont pas comme un droit universel j'ai
trouvé cette expression dans le rapport
des citoyens elle m'a un petit peu voilà
mais un petit peu marqué donc non comme
un droit universel mentionné dans le
rapport de la convention citoyenne mais
comme un ultime recours
la décision relèvera du Parlement garant
de la souveraineté nationale et du fait
majoritaire car la question est
sociétale néanmoins comparé à d'autres
elle se distingue elle se distingue
parce qu'elle implique de façon majeure
le médecin c'est pourquoi à consensus
doit être trouvé avec le corps médical
la clause de conscience permet aux
médecins de ne pas pratiquer telle ou
tel acte en l'espèce il s'agirait de
l'acte létal mais le médecin est tenu de
contacter un médecin qui accepterait de
le faire
de tout temps des médecins ont t'aider
des malades à mourir par compassion pour
ne pas les abandonner dans le cadre d'un
colloque singulier aussi les médecins
qui accepteront de pratiquer l'acte
létal l'accepteront certainement pour
leur patient dans la volonté
d'accompagner leur patient jusqu'au bout
de la route jusqu'au terme de leur vie
mais il est très peu probable qu'ils
acceptent de prendre en charge un
patient dans ce seul objectif devenir
des sortes de docteur tanator si vous
permettez l'expression
donc une des difficultés principales de
légiférer est ici que la loi va devoir
se frayer un chemin vers la volonté du
patient sans entraver le colloque
singulier entre le patient et son
médecin ce colloque doit être maintenu
ne peut être empêché par un droit qui
serait à droite créance à demander à
exiger l'euthanasie ou le suicide
assisté a le droit trop affirmé mais
très ta mal ce colloque singulier
tellement importante tellement de
nécessaire aux patients c'est pourquoi
plutôt que de parler des critères de
minutie qu'on leur comme l’ont fait
beaucoup de nos pays voisins peut-être
faut-il se concentrer sur le moyen
d'assurer au patients qu'il sera entendu
tout en protégeant un espace d'autonomie
professionnelle qui permettra de
respecter la singularité inhérente à
chaque situation
une loi ne répondra jamais à toutes les
situations
et une telle démarche n'empêche pas une
intervention collégiale afin que le
médecin ne porte pas seul la décision
qu'on ne puisse ressentir une toute
puissance du médecin et puis aussi pour
permettre à un autre regard un regard
collégial sur la situation du patient
quoi qu'il en soit le droit et ses
limites devront être suffisamment
solides pour résister à leur dépassement
tout en permettant un espace d'autonomie
professionnelle qui je me permets
d'assister respecte la singularité
inhérente à chaque situation
alors dans notre paysage actuel de la
santé publique les usagers du système de
santé ont peur ils craignent d'être race
ils ont besoin d'être rassurés ils
doivent être rassurés ils doivent savoir
qu'ils seront pris en charge de la
meilleure façon qui puisse être et que
si cette prise en charge ne peut calmer
leur souffrance une ultime solution leur
sera apportée mais les usagers
sont d'abord sans doute des citoyens des
citoyens auxquels les pouvoirs publics
doivent offrir une société qui
privilégie la vie en apportant aide
attention au plus vulnérables en
prodiquant les soins le plus longtemps
et le plus raisonnablement possible en
accompagnant ensuite dignement le décès
en dernier recours et je crois pouvoir
dire qu'on peut en tant qu'usage et pour
soi-même souhaiter savoir qu'on sera
entendu le jour où on décide de dire
stop au traitement sans pour autant en
tant que citoyen souhaitez-vous dans une
société qui ouvrirait trop largement la
possibilité d'une famille voilà ce que
je voulais vous dire comme il m'a été
demandé de résumer quelques arrêts si
j'ai encore quelques minutes je le fais
oui alors là c'est
bon je vais pas vous faire un cours de
droit mais je vous résume les décisions
de la CEDH voilà comment on m'a demandé
de le faire effectivement la Cour
européenne a plusieurs reprises c'est
prononcé sur la question de l'aide
active à mourir alors je les ai prises
dans l'ordre mon homme m'a donné les
décisions dans la répit pretty contre
Royaume-Uni 2002 la Cour a consacré le
droit au refus de soins tout en refusant
d'interpréter l'article 2 droit à la vie
comme conférence un droit diamétralement
opposé au droit à la vie à savoir le
droit de mourir ou un droit à l'eau
d'authermie pardon à l'autodétermination
en ce sens qu'il donnerait à tout
individu le droit de choisir la mort
plutôt que la vie ça ça a été dit dès
2002 avant notre première législation
2005 ensuite l'affaire as contre Suisse
2011 un patient Suisse atteint de
troubles psychiques demandées que lui
soit délivrer du Pinteau berbital je
suis pas sûr que le prononcer comme il
faut afin de pouvoir disait-il se
suicider de manière digne
la Cour a estimé que le droit positif
helvet en ce qui liait la délivrance de
la substance à une prescription médicale
ne contrôvenait pas au dispositions de
l'article 8 vie privée de la convention
ainsi la Cour a vu dans le droit pour un
individu pour une personne de décider de
sa femme vie un aspect du droit au
respect de la vie privée mais elle s'est
retranchée derrière l'absence de
consensus des états pour ne pas leur
imposer d'obligations positive en ce
domaine
ensuite 2012
la ricoche contre Allemagne ici il
s'agissait du mari le mari requérant
avait fait valoir que le refus des
juridictions nationales d'examiner au
fond son crief relatif au refus de
l'Institut Fédéral d'accorder à son
épouse l'autorisation d'obtenir là
encore la dose nécessaire de
pato-parpital qui lui aurait permis de
se suicider dans l'intimité de son foyer
plutôt qu'allon et pénible voyage vers
Zurich avait entraîné une violation du
droit qu'il tient de l'article 8 là
encore le droit au respect de la vie
privée familiale et ici la cour
franchise étape elle franchit une étape
en condamnant l'interdiction du principe
du suicide assisté qui était en vigueur
en Allemagne en estimant qu'une
juridiction doit pouvoir juger au cas
par cas du bien fondé des demandes
individuelles au suicide
et elle en conclut que les étapes partis
à la Convention étaient loin d'avoir un
ski d'avoir atteint un consensus sur ce
sujet et qu'il y avait lieu dans ce
contexte une fois encore de reconnaître
une marge d'appréciation considérable
on arrive en 2013
2013 l'affaire grosse contre Suisse les
médecins consultés par la requérante ont
refusé avaient refusé de lui délivrer
l'ordonnance qu'elle demandait aux motif
que celle-ci est là c'est intéressant ne
souffrait d'aucune pathologie clinique
la Cour européenne a condamné la Suisse
pour violation de l'article 8 eu égard à
sa législation qui tout en permettant on
le sait d'obtenir une dose mortelle de
médicaments ne fournit pas de directives
suffisamment clair pour définir
l'ampleur de ce droit et ce sera une des
questions qui va se poser à vous la
cours a jugé que cette incertitude quant
à l'issue de sa demande à causé une
angoisse considérable à Madame cross ce
qui ne se serait pas produit en présence
directive clair et approuvée par l'État
dont acte
et viens ensuite ce sera le dernier
l'arrêt mortier contre Belgique du 4
octobre 2022 donc là nous sommes
beaucoup plus proche dans le temps c'est
l'arrêt enfin là il s'agissait de
la Belgique la Cour a été saisi par un
requérant qui invoqué une violation de
l'article 2 de la Convention européenne
à la suite de l'euthanasie de sa mère sa
mère qui souffre et de dépression
chronique depuis une quarantaine
d'années
le requérant prétend que l'État a manqué
à ses obligations positives de
protection de la vie puisque la
procédure prévue par la loi sur
l'euthanasie n'aurait pas été respecté
et rendant ainsi illusoire les garanties
qu'elle prévoit
la cour dans cet arrêt rappelle qu'il
n'est pas possible de déduire de
l'article 2 de la Convention a droit à
mourir tout en retenant que le droit à
la vie consacré par l'article 2
n'interdisez pas en soi une
dépénalisation conditionnelle par la loi
belge de Lucianne de l'euthanasie et là
où l'arrêt est intéressant c'est que la
Cour est non pour la première fois quand
ce sens la mise en place de garantie
adéquate et suffisante et nécessaire et
elle observe trois éléments l'existence
d'un cadre législatif concernant les
actes préalables
le respect de ce cadre et l'existence
d'un contrôle a posteriori présentant
des garanties suffisantes bon ici dans
dans l'affaire mortier
s'agissant du contrôle a postériori la
cour à jussé à juger les garanties
insuffisantes ce n'est pas le plus
intéressant le plus intéressant et
la portée plus générale dans
l'observance par la Cour de ces trois
éléments je vous remercie de votre
attention
pensez précisions merci de votre
intervention monsieur Jeannet
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs c'est toujours
un plaisir pour universitaire d'être
invité à présenter le fruit de ses
recherches dans l'espoir de pouvoir
contribuer à éclairer la représentation
nationale m'avait demandé de venir vous
éclairer sur le cadre juridique de la
fin de vie dans différents pays
professeurs de droit constitutionnel je
m'intéresserai surtout à des principes
constitutionnels à des décisions rendues
par des juridictions constitutionnelles
et au contexte dans lequel certaines
lois ont été élaborées dans d'autres
pays conduisant à dépénaliser à
autoriser ou à organiser une aide active
à mourir sous certaines conditions et je
partirai à cet égard d'une tension qui
traverse de nombreuses démocraties
contemporaines d'un côté la provocation
de sa propre mort est un acte
d'autodétermination personnelle qui
prend la forme classique dans sa
brutalité même du suicide d'un autre
côté c'est un acte qui intéresse la
société entière en tant quicontre car le
cours normal des choses
et c'est à la rencontre de ces deux
tendances que différents parlements
différents juges constitutionnels on
choisit de faire évoluer leurs droits
dans le sens d'un plus grand
accompagnement des candidats ou très bas
encore faut-il préciser ce dont il est
question l'aide à mourir peut renvoyer à
quatre actions distinctes qui soulève
des questions différentes du point de
vue du droit dans l'ordre de la
préparation de la mort on peut
distinguer l'interruption des
traitements les médecins se contentent
de laisser la mort survenir en son temps
en arrêtant de soigner et les soins
palliatifs qui conduisent à pour les
médecins à prodiguer des soins destinés
à soulager la souffrance du patient
notamment dans le cadre d'une sédation
profonde et continue jusqu'au décès à
l'inverse dans l'ordre du déclenchement
de la mort qui soulève des questions
juridiques tout à fait distinctes
forment plus active d'aide à mourir on
distingue habituellement l'assistance au
suicide comme la rappeler l'une de mes
collègues avant moi on accompagne le
patient qui commet infini l'acte
mortifère contrairement à l'euthanasie
strictosens qui veut que l'acte
mortifère délibéré soit commis par un
auxiliaire parfois situation parfois
nécessaire pour les plus malades qui ne
pourraient pas se suicider eux-mêmes
distinction qui est décisive en droit
mais qui en pratique est assez fine on
l'imagine et ça soulève évidemment des
questions en la matière il est assez
courant de d'évoquer certains de nos
voisins certains des pays qui sont
autour de nous pour différentes raisons
tout d'abord parce que certains d'entre
eux ont privilégié des législations
particulièrement libérales en la matière
d'autre part parce que des Français
anonymes ou célèbres ont décidé d'aller
finir leurs jours dans ces pays et enfin
parce que ces pays sont parfois invoqués
mise en avant comme une forme
d'épouvantail argumentatif en les
présentant non sans caricature comme des
lieux où l'on pourrait orchestrer sa
mort en cas de simples spleen passagers
et où on pourrait accéder à des produits
locaux les taux pardon de façon tout à
fait facile je passerai rapidement la
Suisse évidemment qui dès 1941 a prévu
que l'assistance au suicide dont le
mobile est altruiste n'était plus
réprimés les Pays-Bas bien sûr qui ont
des pénalisé l'assistance au suicide et
l'euthanasie en 2001 sous certaines
conditions la demande répétée du malade
lorsqu'il peut l'exprimer le caractère
incurable de sa maladie la vie prit
auprès d'autres médecins et le
signalement de la mort aux autorités
quant à la Belgique ou je comprends que
certains membres de sa commission se
sont rendus récemment elle a dépénalisé
le Tanasi actif en 2002 sous certaines
conditions majorité du patient ce qui a
été étendu en 2014 au mineur dans des
circonstances qui soulèvent des
questions formulation de demande
volontaire réfléchie et répétées
situation médicale
issue pardon et patient qui fait état
d'une souffrance psychique ou
psychologique constante quant aux autres
États le Luxembourg en 2009 pour
l'assistance aux suicide et l'euthanasie
l'Espagne en 95 pour l'assistance au
suicide et en 2021 pour l'euthanasie et
plus loin de nous la Nouvelle-Zélande
situation intéressante car le choix a
été fait de recourir au référendum pour
légaliser l'euthanasie en 2020 ce sont
des situations que l'on invoque aussi
ièrement alors quel est le rôle joué
plus particulièrement par les juges
constitutionnels parce que c'est la
question qui m'a été posée dans
l'évolution de ces législations sur la
fin de vie
première remarque les juges de manière
générale s'attachent on peut penser que
c'est le cas des individus qui composent
ces juridictions c'est en tout cas un
argument qui est volontiers mis en avant
à se montrer en retrait à laisser les
Parlement être les forums pertinents
pour trancher ces questions épineuses
deuxième observation il arrive néanmoins
que les jeux soient plus actifs comme
nous le verrons qu'il conduisent à
provoquer en quelque sorte des
législations dans des conditions qui
soulèvent un certain nombre de questions
autre observation les juges sont souvent
sollicités les juges constitutionnels en
particulier en effet dans certains pays
on peut noter qu'il est parfois plus
facile pour les personnes qui défendent
la mise en place d'une aide active à
mourir d'accéder au prétoire de juge
constitutionnel que de pousser les
parlementaires à se saisir eux-mêmes de
la question ainsi s'explique le nombre
important de décisions rendues à ce
sujet par différentes juridictions
constitutionnelles mais aussi par des
organes
supra-nationaux de protection des droits
de l'homme à de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme dont on vient de
parler et notamment cette décision
mortier contre Belgique dont chers
collègues vous venez de parler qui est
particulièrement important dans la
mesure où la Cour européenne des droits
de l'homme dans ce cadre-là affirmé
qu'une loi
autorisant le thanazisme mais
connaissait pas de ce simple fait le
droit à la vie garantie par l'article 2
de la Convention tout en refusant
l'existence d'un droit à mourir et en
laissant comme vous l'avez dit aux États
une large marge d'appréciation
alors les relations entre les juges
constitutionnels et les parlements qu'on
rentre un peu plus dans le détail sont
assez diverses et il est possible de les
ramener à 4 grandes configurations
première configuration le cas dans
lequel une réforme parlementaire et
consolidé par une juridiction
constitutionnelle le cas d'école en
l'occurrence et le cas belge le
Parlement en 2002 comme je l'ai dit à
autoriser l'euthanasie l'a ouvert aux
mineurs en 2014 et le 29 octobre 2015 la
Cour constitutionnelle a inféré du droit
au respect de la vie privée le droit de
décider de mettre fin à sa vie pour
éviter une fin de vie indigne et pénible
deuxième cas de figure le cas dans
lequel une réforme parlementaire est
neutralisée par une juridiction
constitutionnelle et là c'est le cas qui
nous est donné par le Portugal ou en
2021 le Parlement a dépénalisé à la fois
l'assistance au suicide et le tanazi
sous conditions dans un cadre médical
avant que le Président de la République
opposait à la réforme conservateur si
oppose en saisissant le Tribunal
constitutionnel qui a déclaré la loi
inconstitutionnelle au nom du fait que
cette loi comportait des catégories
juridiques trop vagues notamment en ce
qui concerne est la question des
souffrances le Parlement a adopté une
nouvelle loi qui a subi un veto
présidentiel en novembre 2021 et une
nouvelle loi est encore en discussion on
a donc un jeu de d'aller-retour de
ping-pong entre le Parlement d'un côté
le Tribunal constitutionnel et le
président de l'autre
qui n'est pas terminé troisième
configuration la configuration dans
laquelle il y a une incitation
juridictionnelle qui conduit à une
réforme parlementaire sur ce point 3
situations distinctes méritent d'être
distinguées tout d'abord la manière
forte qui nous est montré par le
Tribunal constitutionnel fédéral
allemand qui le 26 février 2020 alors
qu'il n'existait pas de loi autorisant
l'aide active à mourir à censurer une
loi qui prohibait l'assistance au
suicide dans un cadre professionnel en
tirant du principe de dignité de la
personne humaine écrit dans la
Constitution dont il avait déjà inféré
un principe un droit au libre
épanouissement de sa personnalité un
droit de choisir sa mort et c'est ça la
nouveauté de la décision qui n'est pas
limitée aux maladies graves ou
incurables et donc là on a un tribunal
constitutionnel qui consacre un principe
constitutionnel de droits de choisir sa
mort et qui conduit le législateur à
essayer de suivre ce principe
éventuellement en adoptant mais ils sont
en train de travailler sur ce point une
loi en la matière
de manière plus détournée il arrive que
des juges constitutionnels se fonde sur
des réserves d'interprétation pour
pousser le Parlement à légiférer alors
qu'est-ce qu'on appelle une réserve
interprétation pour mémoire dans le
cadre en tout cas du Conseil
constitutionnel français c'est le cas
dans lequel une juridiction
constitutionnelle déclare une loi
conforme à la Constitution en précisant
que cette déclaration de
constitutionnalité et sous réserve du
fait que telle ou tel article est
interprété de tel ou telle manière on
est donc dans un cas où le juge
constitutionnel qui d'habitude pour
reprendre une distinction du Doyen Vedel
n'utilise que la gomme peut
marginalement utiliser le crayon en
essayant en affirmant le fait que la loi
doit être légèrement réécrite dans tel
ou telle direction en l'occurrence c'est
ce qui s'est passé en Colombie ou en
1997 la Cour constitutionnelle a créé
une cause d'irresponsabilité pénale en
matière de tanasie tout en invitant le
Parlement à légiférer sur la question
en 2000 le Parlement a réagi à l'inverse
en prohibant de façon générale
l'euthanasie en 2015 le ministre de la
Santé a lui adopté un acte qui
légalisait en pratique l'euthanasie
contre la loi et en 2021 la Cour a
déclaré que la loi pénale prohibant le
thanasie était conforme à la
Constitution sous réserve qu'on souhaite
exclu l'acte réalisé avec le
consentement du malade quel que soit
l'état d'avancement de la maladie et
tout en invitant encore une fois le
Parlement à légiférer pour mieux
protéger le droit de mourir dans la
dignité enfin la manière encore plus
douce d'agir consiste à moduler dans le
temps les effets d'une décision
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire des
juridictions constitutionnelles on la
possibilité de dire je déclare telle loi
contraire à la Constitution mais je
repousse dans le temps les effets de ma
décision en particulier pour laisser au
Parlement le soin de légiférer dans
l'intervalle
en l'occurrence c'est le choix qui a été
privilégié au Canada ou en 2015 la Cour
suprême a jugé que la prohibition pénale
de l'aide à mourir méconnaissait le
droit à la vie à la liberté et à la
sécurité des personnes telles qu'il les
garantit par l'article 7 de la Charte
canadienne des droits et libertés en
tant qu'elles prive de cette aide
certaines catégories de malade la Cour a
repoussé d'un an puis de 4 mois les
effets de sa décision et entre temps le
Parlement a adopté une loi se conformant
à la décision de la Cour enfin la
quatrième configuration que l'on observe
est celle dans laquelle la réforme
procède de la juridiction elle-même en
raison d'une inertie prolongée du
Parlement alors même que du temps lui
avait été laissé pour aller dans cette
direction c'est la situation qui nous
est donnée par la Cour c'est l'exemple
qui nous est donné par la Cour
constitutionnelle italienne dans toute
une saga qui a conduit à la cour à
rendre plusieurs décisions dans
l'affaire Marco kapato alors en quelques
mots marquer au capato était un ancien
parlementaire européen
artiste qui a volontairement été
accompagné un DJ qui est très connu qui
avait subi un accident de voiture très
grave ensuite pour y bénéficier d'une
assistance au suicide il est revenu en
Italie il est allé voir les carabineries
en disant voilà arrêtez moi je viens de
commettre une infraction en regard du
code pénal italien tout ça pour
provoquer un grand débat sur l'aide à
mourir et en l'occurrence à l'occasion
de son procès pénal a été soulevé la
question de la constitutionnalité de la
loi pénale qui fondait les poursuites à
son encontre et dans ce cadre là la Cour
constitutionnelle en 2018 a rendu une
première ordonnance en principe
provisoire mais qui en réalité on va le
voir fixait déjà un certain nombre de
choses pour dire que en gros
il fallait dans le débat entre liberté
de s'autodéterminer d'un côté et
protection de la vie humaine de l'autre
reconnaître que il y avait des causes
d'irresponsabilité pénale qui devait
être reconnues dans le creux de la loi
pénale interdisant de manière générale
suicide assisté ou plutôt l'assistance
au suicide lorsque la pathologie est
incurable que les souffrances ont
intolérables que le maintien en vie est
artificiel et que la capacité de prendre
des décisions libres et conscientes et
néanmoins maintenues dans ce cas de
figure nous dit la Cour
constitutionnelle il convient de créer
une cause d'irresponsabilité pénale mais
je ne tranche pas cette question
moi-même nous dit le jeu je repousse
d'un an non pas les effets de ma
décision mais la décision elle-même
j'affirme que cette décision n'est que
provisoire et d'ici un an si le
Parlement a légiféré nous verrons bien
le Parlement un an plus tard ne
l'igifère pas et un an plus tard en 2019
la cour rend une décision définitive
constatant l'inertie prolongée du
législateur et notant que la loi pénale
est inconstitutionnel en tant qu'elles
ne prévoit pas une exception dans le cas
de figure qui avait été identifié un an
plus tôt
je passe rapidement sur le fait que en
2022 troisième décision dans la saga
kapato le même kapato avait sollicité un
référendum abrogatif d'initiative
populaire qui est une procédure qui
permet de demander l'abrogation d'une
disposition législative par référendum
dans ce cadre la cour opère un contrôle
et la cour à bloqué en l'occurrence un
tel référendum qui portait non plus sur
le suicide assisté l'assistance se
suicide pardon mais sur l'euthanasie en
somme la cour italienne dans ce cas
précis a écrit la loi sur l'assistance
au suicide en fait du fait du de
l'inertie certes du Parlement elle a
évité que la loi évolue en matière
d'euthanasie c'est un cas intéressant où
le cours qu'on ou une cour
constitutionnelle à faire en
l'occurrence cavalier seul voilà pour
mon parcours je j'ai d'éventuelles
éléments de réflexion sur le Conseil
constitutionnel mais peut-être qu'on va
garder ça pour d'éventuelles questions
alors
ensuite
Michel meunier
un petit peu sur
la place de cette audition aujourd'hui
en commission puisque nous sommes qu'il
y a un travail qui est en cours en tout
cas sur la mission une mission sur les
soins palliatifs
heureusement j'ai pas pu y participer
mais
je reviendrai pas sur le j'allais dire
sur le fond du problème quel est un
problème est très long complexe on a eu
encore donc pas plus tard que lundi la
vie de cette commission avec 150
personnes qui ont été tirées au sort qui
a été rendus lundi après-midi ou lundi
matin je sais plus enfin en tout cas
c'était le lundi
je veux pas revenir sur le fond parce
que on ouvrirait un débat
que j'espère en aura parce que j'espère
bien qu'on aura un texte législatif qui
fera avancer ce sujet qui est
extrêmement complexe moi je voulais
juste
me lever contre une phrase que vous avez
dit madame qui m'a vraiment fait
sursauter ça s'est entendu d'ailleurs
et que je trouve extrêmement choquante
quand vous dites
parce qu'il manque de place à l'hôpital
il faudrait on court un risque que les
soignants
décident j'allais dire de tuer des gens
simplement pour libérer des places c'est
intolérable pour moi et je pense que
pour beaucoup d'autres ici c'est
vraiment une insulte à la profession
médicale et aux professions de santé que
je ne peux pas tolérer donc je suis
devenu à vous le dire
alors en fait je n'ai absolument pas
souhaité dire une telle une telle chose
je dis simplement que lorsque les lits
sont limitées en soins palliatifs
et les il y a quand même il y a quand
même à répondre voilà les gens sont dans
leur lit
l'hôpital fonctionne à sa manière il va
y avoir de nouveau de nouvelles
personnes qui vont arriver
que faire et regarder ce qui s'est passé
pendant la covid pendant la covid il y a
eu aussi
des situations intolérables je trouve
que ce sont des situations intolérables
et en fait même si on ne peut pas les
supporter elles existent et je crois que
c'est indispensable de prendre en
considération ces situations pour que le
législateur mais aussi pour que l'État
intervienne pour mettre à disposition
tous les moyens qu'il faut pour la fin
de vie mais qu'on n'est pas assez de
place en soins palliatifs on en est tous
d'accord mais que vous puissiez de dire
que un médecin en conscience va choisir
qu'il faut gérer il faut gérer un
service il faut gérer une unité
et voilà donc il y a pas le choix en
fait
concernant la première remarque des
milliards pour mes rôles je rappelle que
la mission confiée à
Christine bonfanty Corinne Imbert et
Michel Meunier est la suite de leur
mission qu'elles avaient fait sur les
soins palliatifs mais qu'elle est
maintenant intitulée mission sur la fin
de vie
je voulais rappeler que on assimile
souvent le texte les textes qui vont
venir il y aura un texte au président de
la République Laeti quel sera-t-il ça on
le verra
pour l'instant
souvent on présente en disant la loi
leonétique laisse et méconnue il y a
passé directives anticipées il y a pas
assez de l'aide sur un palliatifs même
si on peut faire du palliatif à domicile
et je pense qu'il faut vraiment aussi
qu'on axe vers là on présente un peu
souvent la loi à venir comme la suite de
la loi le mytique classe pour moi c'est
totalement différent la loi c'est une
loi sur des une citation profonde et
continue jusqu'au dessin en cas de de
mort imminente à court terme pour
soulager les souffrances parce que
beaucoup de gens souhaitent certes
mourir souhaitent surtout le non
acharnement thérapeutique et pouvoir
avoir une mort apaisée et c'est souvent
aussi le souhait de leur famille là on
passe sur un autre sur légifère on va
passer sur après chacun a le droit
d'avoir son avis et de savoir ce sur
quoi on s'orient parce qu'il y a des
différences entre les pays mais je
n'aime pas bien qu'on assimile et je
pense que Jean Le n'était-il ne l'aime
pas beaucoup d'ailleurs qu'on assimile
un texte à venir sur la suite de sa loi
non c'est une loi différente c'est
comment on répond à une mort choisie par
nos citoyens comment on y répond est-ce
qu'on y répond ou non est-ce qu'on y
répond pas une assistance au suicide ou
est-ce qu'on va jusqu'en effet
l'euthanasie tel qu'elle est pratiquée
ou c'est vraiment entre le médecin et le
patient que cela se joue mais je pense
qu'il faut qu'on soit qu'on est bien ça
en tête parce que sinon on mélange un
peu tout et
même si je comprends la maladresse qui a
eu mais c'est vrai que il faudrait pas
que parce qu'il y a pas de soins
palliatifs non c'est différent c'est une
mort choisie un citoyen peut exprimer un
choix de de mort ou de fin de vie mais
c'est un texte à mes yeux totalement
différent sur lequel on devra discuter
Michel meunier
merci madame la Présidente d'avoir remis
ce contexte
donc je suis une des co-rapporteurs avec
Christine beaufantili de ça et Corinne
Imbert sur cette question et je trouve
que cette audition de ce matin vient
bien
complété complexifier même les auditions
nombreuses que nous menons depuis le
début si on veut bien prendre en compte
le travail précédent autour des soins
palliatifs
et j'avoue que
la semaine dernière on nous avions une
table ronde de philosophe il y en a un
qui a dit que cette one pourrait pas
être consensuelle ça je le pense
franchement il y aura des éléments de
consensualité on en connaît entre nous
même ici dans cette commission des
affaires sociales du Sénat et puis il y
en aura qui seront plus clivantes et
après ce sera aux politiques de prendre
la responsabilité de le faire moi je
veux bien parce que je vous ai entendu
en tout cas merci mesdames de nous avoir
redonné aussi le sens de l'éthique dans
le droit et je suis très sensible avec
ces valeurs
à la fois de non malfaisance de
bienfaits bienveillance et de
l'autonomie de la du patient et c'est
vraiment de ça dont il s'agit moi je
voulais vous questionner monsieur Julien
Jeannenet parce que vous avez une
spécificité qui est intéressante et moi
quand on est allé avec la présidente et
mes collègues en Belgique j'ai été
frappé sur une question qui n'est pas
une question de sémantique je pense
parce que les Belges ils ont pas
légalisé l'euthanasie ils ont dépénalisé
l'euthanasie et sur leur brochure c'est
bien inscrit loi dépénalisant
l'euthanasie alors je suis pas du tout
juriste de formation et je voudrais bien
avoir la la perception l'analyse de ce
que vous faites qu'est-ce que quel est
cette grande différence entre voilà les
termes et par de là les actes
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames merci Monsieur pour pour vos
interventions juste en complément dire à
Emilienne qu'on a voulu associer
l'ensemble des commissaires de façon en
été toutes les trois d'accord pour
ouvrir à l'ensemble des commissaires ces
auditions tout en complément des
auditions évidemment que nous faisons en
rapporteur
j'ai trois quatre questions mais très
courte et avec peut-être des réponses
très courtes aussi parce que sinon on va
encore y passer beaucoup de temps ou
sinon vous me répondrez si vous voulez
peut-être par écrit sur si vous voulez
dans la formulation plus longue
en tant que juriste l'acte de thanasie
est-il un soin
quel est votre définition de la mort
naturelle ou d'une mort naturelle
vous pouvez disserter certainement trop
longuement donc et juste comme ça je
fais peur de mes questions mes questions
sont courtes les réponses sont
certainement longues mais donc voilà en
quelques mots puis tout le monde aura
accès au compte rendu de la commission
donc on pourra et on fera il y aura un
rapport où tout ça sera mentionné si
vous me faites des réponses écrites
quelles conséquences juridique que
peuvent engendrer demain liberté de
demander sa mort et dignité et j'allais
même rajouter égalité puisque vous avez
évoqué l'égalité
et
quel quel risque de pente glissante
voilà je vais sûrement d'autres
questions mais je vais me tenir assez
quatre questions très courtes vous le
reconnaîtrez
alors voilà je vais me lancer de façon
rapide mais je n'ai pas toutes les
réponses alors le thanazi
bon état qui consiste à injecter d'une
façon quelconque un produit létale afin
que la personne décède
évidemment c'est pas un soin dans le
sens où c'est pas une mesure de confort
c'est pour ça je pense que
que la réponse est totalement subjective
en fonction des personnes qui répondront
bien sûr c'est pas un soin c'est
simplement la dernière solution la façon
d'arrêter des souffrances qu'on parvait
pas arrêter lorsqu'une personne est
condamnée c'est pas un soin ça ne
procure pas un confort quelconque
c'est une façon d'arrêter les
souffrances
alors ensuite une mort naturelle dans
votre dans le contexte dans lequel nous
sommes je pense que c'est une mort qui
s'oppose à la mort provoquée par une
substance injectée dans cet objectif
ce que je continue peut-être vous allez
répondre à la suite
je crois qu'ils ont disons la personne
décédée est considérée décédée mort
naturelle ça veut d'ailleurs un peu été
le cas lorsqu'on avait examiné la
proposition de loi de Marie-Pierre la
Gontrie que rapportait Michel meunier il
y avait cette notions qui
apparaît compliquées parce que une mort
naturelle qui est digne après un coup de
tringle c'est quand même compliqué
intellectuellement à envisager mais sur
le plan juridique ça tient ça pour moi
non
parce que à ce moment là qu'est-ce
qu'une mort non naturelle voilà pour moi
une mort naturelle c'est l'achèvement de
la vie lorsque le corps
l'organisme cesse de fonctionner
lorsqu'on injecte une un produit afin
qu'il cesse de fonctionner
voilà maintenant je pense que les
philosophes répondraient peut-être mieux
que nous en tout cas que moi sur la
notion de nature mais non pour moi c'est
pas une mort naturelle
ment naturel je pense pour éviter des
poursuites donc la personne qui a fait
l'injection ne soit pas possible mais
vous allez peut-être mega vous continuez
sur vos réponses je continue alors
la troisième était les conséquences
juridiques de la demande de mort
vis-à-vis de la dignité je crois
alors oui concernant la dignité bon je
pense pas que l'idée soit de se lancer
dans
dans un débat sur la dignité on va
simplement dire que la dignité peut-être
défini de façon rapide comme notre égal
appartenance à l'humanité et je crois
que cette notion alors dans un rapport
que j'ai coordonné que je vous ai
communiqué d'ailleurs cet été on a
abandonné parmi les arguments qu'on
recensés la dignité tout simplement
parce que là la façon
de voir le respect de la dignité selon
qu'on permet l'acte létal ou non et
totalement subjectif voilà maintenant il
est certain qu'il est
il pourrait y avoir mais j'ai pas
d'inquiétude ça n'arrivera pas ça
n'arrivera pas des cas dans lesquels la
dignité ne soit pas respectée mais je
pense que c'est pas notre débat bien sûr
que la dignité sera respectée simplement
chacun d'entre vous aura peut-être une
notion différente du respect de cette
dignité parce que tout le monde reste
digne jusqu'à la fin de séjour c'est
pour ça que j'aime pas beaucoup
l'expression de mourir dans la dignité à
naître humain reste digne parce que la
dignité est un attribut tout ça tout
simplement de l'humanité simplement
toute la question de respecter au mieux
cette dignité et c'est là où je pense
qu'il n'y a pas de de réponse objective
en tout cas trancher
oui c'était
alors le risque de pente glissante et le
risque est alors on appelle ça oui d'une
façon géométrique parce que je prends
exemple sur ce qui s'est passé et
notamment là où était Théo Boer c'est en
nous
voilà je crois qu'on a tous été marqué
par cet article de Théo Bauer ce qui est
certain c'est que de toute façon la loi
ne répondra pas à toutes les demandes à
toutes les situations c'est ce que vous
disez le consensus total n'existe pas
donc certaines personnes se verront
refuser les fortunes droite tel qu'il
sera défini et ces personnes
pourront défendre leur position
notamment vis-à-vis des juridictions en
invoquant une stigmatisation ou une
inégalité des droits et c'est là où on
risque avec une logique juridique et qui
détendent ce que vous aurez décidé parce
que certaines personnes qui ne feront
pas partie du dispositif pourront faire
valoir qu'il y a là une inégalité
merci jamais ensuite si vous voulez
compléter merci madame la Présidente
alors tout d'abord sur la distinction
entre dépénalisations ou légalisation
alors là c'est une distinction générale
en droit quand vous dépénalisez vous
faites en sorte qu'un comportement qui
était incriminable qui était susceptible
de justifier le fait que la personne qui
effectuait ce comportement pouvait être
atteinal n'était plus ne devient devient
libre au sens d'un principe général de
liberté en droit pénale qui fait que on
ne peut punir qu'à raison de ce qui a
été explicitement interdit dès lors que
vous
par une loi vous décidez que le code
pénal ne punit plus tel comportement ce
comportement rentre dans le champ
général des très nombreux comportements
qui relèvent du principe général de
liberté la légalisation qui peut
d'ailleurs croiser partiellement la
dépénalisation elle conduit à ce qu'une
loi explicitement autorise les individus
à agir d'une certaine manière avec tout
ce que permet une loi c'est-à-dire pas
uniquement prévoir que c'est désormais
autorisé mais aussi prévoir les
conditions dans lesquelles cela est
autorisé et donc lorsque vous
dépénalisez vous dites simplement ça
tombe dans le champ général d'un
principe de liberté lorsque vous
légalisez et bien vous pouvez fixer des
critères des conditions des procédures
en disant voilà ce qu'il faudra faire si
désormais vous souhaitez accéder à
l'assistance à un suicide assisté ou à
une euthanasie en ce qui concerne madame
la sénatrice les questions que vous
posiez sur certaines des plus grandes
notions du droit public et
constitutionnel notamment français la
liberté tout d'abord en l'occurrence
évidemment c'est très difficile de se
prononcer sur un texte sans même le
projet de loi qui va être le point de
départ peut-être de vos réflexions et de
vos travaux
le principe de liberté on peut
considérer que la liberté serait accrue
par l'ouverture faite aux individus de
d'accéder à ces fins de vie là
la dignité alors la dignité c'est
évidemment une question tout à fait
hypineuse c'est une catégorie juridique
dont les contours sont extrêmement
vagues dont la charge politique morale
est évidemment très importante et donc
le fait d'invoquer la dignité en
l'occurrence il me semble pas que il y a
une solution toute prête que l'on puisse
déduire de ce principe de dignité en
effet on peut tout à fait invoquer la
dignité au soutien de l'idée selon
laquelle il faut permettre aux individus
de choisir les conditions dans
lesquelles il souhaite mourir en
particulier pour ceux qui sinon vont
subir des souffrances atroces avant la
fin naturelle ou normal c'est juste dire
sinon on ne fait rien des choses et puis
à l'inverse il y a ceux qui vont dire
mais c'est parfaitement indigne de
rendre possible le fait que l'État
autorise une manière ou d'une autre un
acte positif conduisant à la mort des
individus donc à cet égard je ne suis
pas certain que le principe de dignité
vous soit d'une il est incontournable
mais en même temps je suis pas sûr qu'il
lui soit d'une très grande aide en la
matière quant à l'égalité alors je suis
pas certain de comprendre exactement
les cas dans lesquels
et de la légalité puisque ça a été
évoqué tout à l'heure alors oui
c'est les conséquences juridiques qui
peuvent avoir
le principe d'égalité en droit français
est un principe qui est tout à fait
malléable dans la mesure où en gros il
prévoit le fait que des personnes dans
des situations équivalentes doivent être
normalement traité de façon équivalente
et que des personnes dans les situations
différentes peuvent être traités de
manière différente dès lors que la
différence de traitement est en lien
avec la loi qui l'objectif de la loi qui
qui prévoit ce traitement dans les faits
lorsque l'on regarde la manière dont les
juges administratifs et constitutionnel
en particulier utilisent le principe
d'égalité on constate que il y a une
très grande maliabilité de ce principe
qui dépend des paramètres choisis selon
que vous vous concentrez sur telle ou
tel aspect et bien vous allez considérer
que les situations sont analogues au
comparables ou à l'inverse sont
différentes et donc méritent ou grande
possible la possibilité d'un traitement
différencié en l'occurrence il faudrait
voir ce dont on parle est-ce que pour
par principe d'égalité on entend le fait
que ce retraité différemment des
personnes qui
serait en mesure d'exprimer de manière
consciente et répétée jusqu'au dernier
moment leur soin de mourir versus des
personnes qui seraient plus en mesure de
le faire et auquel cas il faudrait se
fonder uniquement sur d'éventuelles
directives anticipées quid en l'absence
de directive anticipée on recroise des
questions qui sont bien connues des
spécialistes est-ce que le principe
d'égalité veut que simplement on
constate que en France des personnes en
général plus favorisées plus informés
savent que il est possible d'aller
mourir en Suisse au Luxembourg ou en
Belgique contrairement à des personnes
qui ne le savent pas ou qui n'y ont pas
accès et qui se trouve à cette égard
dans une situation différente l'égalité
à cet égard me paraît ou être une ligne
une ligne de fond dans l'intégralité de
vos travaux quand je finis sur ce point
un touriste de la pente glissante
c'est évidemment un argument plus
politique que juridique ma réponse de
juriste consiste à dire ou oui mais en
même temps vous êtes législateur c'est à
dire si vous décidez de dire on peut
faire ça vous n'êtes pas obligé de c'est
à vous de faire en sorte l'argument a
été utilisé en 2013 à propos du mariage
ouvert aux personnes de même sexe il y a
eu beaucoup d'arguments de la pente
glissante bon ensuite le législateur a
pu faire évoluer le droit ponctuellement
sur des points précis mais c'était à
chaque fois en réfléchissant en sachant
pourquoi il y a donc l'idée selon
laquelle en bloquant une évolution on se
prémunirait contre le risque d'une
évolution néfaste
ultérieure me semble de toute façon une
idée assez faible dans la mesure où à
tout instant législateur dans 10 ans
pourra avancer avec un grand bon c'est
chaud aussi s'il le souhaite donc faites
ce que vous voulez faire un instant
précis sans trop vous poser la question
des conséquences intellectuelles
idéologiques politiques éventuelle de la
loi que vous êtes en train de préparer
on est cet éclairage en effet juridique
et on attend maintenant le texte à venir
qu'on nous promet pour l'été c'est ça
enfin d'été les fins
avant la fin de l'été on conseillé mais
plutôt ici en septembre merci beaucoup